there's something I'd like to show you
captain
Terry crushed it it works
I've never been more proud of you for
anything in your life I mean I've solved
a lot of cases for you and yet crime has
continued hello Raymond
Madeline I wondered why all the birds
had suddenly stopped singing what brings
you I heard you were under investigation
by Internal Affairs didn't want to miss
that so much time with your ear to the
pavement it's a pity a truck as in run
over your head she's worried about her
motorcycle sitting idle so she wants us
to take it out once a day here
I think you should do this you're more
the biker type I've seen you use a
toothpick in public motorcycles are
death machines I have three kids I'm not
risking it are you saying my life
matters less because I don't conform to
society's heteronormative child-centric
ideals are you really playing the gay
card right now yes Queen
looks like we've both got a pretty bad
case of jerk boss yes yours is an idiot
and mine is a fork tongue and lizard
witch
whoa what's with the cast I sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off
leave the guy alone all right hello
everybody
so he wouldn't say what happened which
can only mean one thing he's in a fight
club no he did it doing something he's
embarrassed by like smiling only
question is how do you hurt your arms
smiling could be a sports injury I
sprained my wrist in college playing
field hockey men's field hockey yeah
it's much more violent than the women's
game we're not allowed to wear anything
that protects our breasts attention
everyone how can hear you speculating
about the nature and origin of my injury
from my office I tripped over an uneven
sidewalk I did not think it was relevant
to your jobs the jobs which you should
all be doing right now get to work
do you want to know how I actually hurt
my wrist
yes I was hula hooping Kevin and I
attend a class for fitness and for fun
oh my god I've mastered all the moves
the pizza toss
the tornado the Scorpion the oopsy
doodle
why are you telling me this
because no one is
will ever believe you no no
you sick son of a
lunch
hello Raymond y'all looking old and
sickly so nice of you to greet us
Madeline I thought surely you'd still be
crushed under that house in Munchkin
land Sticks and Stones Raymond
describing your breakfast
[Music]
Halloween
it's ice time
but you get a head start on Heist prep
good luck I'm already dressed well I'm
also dressed and I made breakfast wait
where are my eggs in my belly
now get a move on it's Heist time I love
Halloween you're not cheddar this is
some common
I've come to ask for your help the
commissioner will be
moment savored so where were we when
people say good morning they mean Hello
when people say how are you they mean
Hello when people say what's up they
mean I am a person not worth talking to
Deputy cheap one she's here to see you
oh please stay Diaz I need a witness in
case her head starts spinning around of
course she turns into a she-wolf
hey Captain
nothing's okay
lunch
circling me like a shark frenzied by
jump
the task force turning into a
career-threatening quagmire an internal
affairs investigation casting doubt upon
my integrity and you ask is everything
okay
I am buffeted by The Winds of my
fosamity and cast about by The Towering
waves of cruel fate yet I a captain I'm
no longer able to command my vessel my
precinct from my customary Helm my
office and you ask is everything okay
I've worked the better part of my years
on Earth overcoming every Prejudice and
fighting for the position I hold and now
I feel it being ripped from my grasp and
with it
the very essence of what defines me as a
man
and you ask
is everything okay
yeah I hear you
my dog has taken over my favorite chair
it's like how did it all slip away
you're going to leave my precinct to end
my task force alone or else you were
lunch meat
you sure you want to go with that one
absolutely it's hilarious right ah there
it is the shriveled husk of Raymond holt
look Gina is that a talking raisin oh I
see you have a knife but what you need
is an umbrella tell them why tell them
why because there's a storm gonna rain
down on you
[Music]
you took the wrong Fluffy Boy
that you came to me to ask for help
shows how much you've matured you know
it all shows how much you've matured
you're with a face no I know why you
refer to this as a Suicide Squad Peralta
because I already want to kill myself
why don't you wait a week you'll
probably die of old age the only way I'm
gonna die is if you touch me with one of
your bony fingers and drag me across the
river sticks you Reaper
[Music]
are you eating an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra pepperoncini
smart
excuse me you need to watch yourself I'm
sorry
cup all right let's everybody just stay
calm here oh what are you gonna arrest
me for dancing
you call that dancing
like this
is dancing
what is happening I'm defusing the
situation
[Music]
[Applause]
oh why is my phone always dead I paid 13
for it don't worry I got it oh my hands
are covered in butter from making butter
I'm on it MasterCard mustard Cord Camera
on all right here we go dancing over
situation diffused
and what do you hope to get out of this
Madeline let me guess revenge on door on
Dorothy for killing your sister
I mean but John Kelly is doing is
terrible yes well said once so we're all
on board this is exciting let's bring it
in huh Suicide Squad on three ready one
two I don't touch other dudes hands oh
that might be me I ate a popsicle
earlier it's probably Madeline
cockroaches release a mucus like
secretion she will leave the city the
clouds will park and the children will
sing once is gone what children
all the children right that was a stupid
question I got her
a Parting Gift tickets to Wicked
in Boston she's moving to a second class
City and I wanted to rub her nose in it
enjoy the understudies Madeleine have
fun watching some chubby Channel with
knockoff and warble her way too popular
what's this meeting about did someone
find my meatball sub hey we would never
have a meeting about that b you are
holding it oh I mean you get Germany's
not over dummy Terry said he has some
news from the office of commissioner
lunch sure what is that human blister
one now does she intend to demote me
even further or perhaps she'll transfer
me to the swamps of New Jersey so I can
Patrol the sinkhole where she was
spawned or it's possible the
announcement has nothing to do with you
okay thank you barata you're right maybe
Madeline wants to inform us all that
she's a juicing a what a chooksen a
Korean toilet ghost lives in an outhouse
wraps her hair around your throat and
chokes you to death while you move your
balance you know what I will give you
six thousand dollars if the announcement
is she's at jukison okay everyone I have
some news the Madeline watch is a Korean
toilet ghost boring we already knew that
Madeline lunch is dead say what now